there's an extra auditory element to it
like with the little jingle it sounds
like money in your pocket which you
won't have any if you buy what's up this
is GQ recommends and today we're talking
about a menswear classic the loafer
[Music]
thank you the origins of the modern
loafer are debatable but they became
popular here in America in the 1930s
through a style called the region which
is a derivative of Norwegian so these
days there are a ton of different loafer
styles that you're probably intimately
familiar with there's Venetian loafers
there's Belgian loafers but today we're
going to focus on three essential Styles
the penny loafer the horse bit loafer
and the tassel loafer each of us were
tasked with a different price range to
find the best possible loafers at that
price
200 and below I got 200 to 400 and I got
400 and up money is No Object so for 200
bucks or less my favorite pick in the
category is this pretty legendary loafer
from GH bassenko it's the Larson region
loafer it's probably pretty close to the
silhouette that you think of when you
think of loafers generally it's called a
penny loafer because as urban legend
goes College Prep stores and young kids
used to stick a penny into that
distinguishing leather strap across the
the top there it's also got what's
called a beef roll which refers to the
leather build up around the vamp I
really like this pair in particular
because it's two-tone which feels really
cool and sort of retro to me they're
just such a classic and they look really
cool fresh out the box they look really
cool beating up you know like when you
when you really live the life in them
totally I think like to Young's point
they almost look even cooler when
they're super beat up like I could see
some skater downtown rocking these with
like cuff Dickies and just beating the
hell out of them my second pick in the
sub 200 category is really sick I'm
excited if you guys to see it it is a
tassel loafer from solavair which is a
Heritage British Shoemaker from
northamptonshire they make really good
really solid really chunky shoes they
actually used to manufacture Doc Martens
this silhouette is really cool for a few
reasons one of them being that it's
Tyler the creators go-to shoe which is
probably the only cosign you ever really
need but it's got this chunky Rubber
Sole that's distinct to what you
probably know from Doc Martens it leans
into the tassel element so it's got like
the kilty detailing right there but it
still has a nice rounded sole it's like
this weird mishmash of old Manish
because of the kilty but then like punk
rock because of the souls like it's just
kind of a perfect shoe it's beautiful
yeah it really is these in particular
are like diesel you know you can do
anything to them and do anything in them
and they'll come out the other side like
looking pretty Fresh So my third pick in
this category is this really cool lug
sole loafer from Sebago I have a small
confession to make these are actually
not below two hundred dollars they're
technically two hundred and fifty
dollars but here's where I'm going to
make my salary the real hack is that
they're almost always on sale and Sebago
might not be happy about me telling you
that so keep it between us so yeah I'm
sticking with my pick in this category
they're what
your Finance friends might call a deal
sled uh which is
a loafer that you wear to the office uh
when you're you know snapping next
taking names but then they're outfitted
with this chunky durable lug sole which
kind of gives them an outdoorsy vent if
if the weather goes awry when you're
running to meet your high-powered
colleagues at the hottest lunch spot
[Music]
if you have a few more bucks to spend
200 to 400 price point my favorite pick
from a brand called black sock and Weber
so this brand is pretty new if you
haven't heard of them I would not be
surprised the founder Chris is a really
cool guy he has pretty deep
sneaker head background and with that
sort of approach he's bringing a really
fresh contemporary angle and you can see
from this pair the leather is not so
typical it's sort of this suede upper
with a elephant skin type of embossing
on it which gives it texture in two
different ways but then you've got this
nice horse bit detail for what you pay
you're getting a lot these are made in
England they have a double layered
leather sole so that's going to make
them last a lot longer but even with
that I find that they're pretty
comfortable they're Goodyear welted
which means that it should be pretty
easy for you to just take them to the
cobbler have them resole it and these
are going to last you a long time I mean
it's guys like Chris like you were
saying who you know have that sneaker
background who like that that was there
like me like that was my introduction to
loving fashion was loving sneakers
loafers are such a great platform to
apply that kind of thinking in terms of
like oh I always want like the newest
hottest colorway I always want to you
know I want to try different materials
and it's like just gives it like a whole
new error and fresh perspective you know
overall it's pretty beefy right like you
look at that silhouette it's like it's
kind of wide which is actually one of
the reasons they are so comfortable I
like them with more relaxed pants to
really emphasize that it just feels like
the proportions are better for wider
pants that said uh I like these with a
pair of shorts too another great option
in this 200 to 400 price range is a
brand called Morehouse they're also a
newer brand but you know they still have
a contemporary Edge but still very much
classic these shoes are made in Spain
which is a country that has a really
long history of shoemaking this is a
really great option you know if you just
graduated or you got your first job like
I would not be mad at getting these as a
present to yourself you know they may
not have that Heritage but they've
definitely got the construction and the
quality and the looks for sure yeah for
sure I mean I feel like The Telltale
sign of a good product is like the
second Gerald pulled it up young and I
both went oh yeah like we've recommended
those like a bunch of people for sure
can you actually talk a little more
about the nails like like what the
significance is so yeah the nails on
here aren't the only Nails in the sole
they're actually in most dress shoes and
hard bottoms or nails like through the
heel too you might eat right you're not
going to see them but they they help
hold the shoe and the sole to the upper
together right you usually see this on
more high-end like bespoke shoemakers
sort of a nod to the more dressy bespoke
feel it's a great value
um Quality shoe handsome like you're
going to have this in your closet for
years last pick in this price range
slides in at 210 bucks right over the
lower limit is this pair of gorgeous
shoes from I never know how to pronounce
it I want to say it's mirman I really
like this brand super handsome I think
it's sort of the nice in between between
black stock and Weber's and the
Morehouse a little bit chunkier but
still pretty Sleek man these are really
pretty up close it's got this gorgeous
deep chocolate color to the Suede and
also a contrast uh leather up here at
the collar it's just really nice it's
just like for barely over 200 there's an
insane amount of detail and oh what I
also really like about these is that
they're online so they're really soft
and that makes them great for wearing in
summer if you're one of those guys that
wears your loafers without without socks
gross
um
yeah bro oh nasty
[Music]
so I had no budget I could pick any
shoes I wanted in the world I decided to
go pretty Classic this is the Gucci 1953
horse bit loafer Gucci didn't invent the
horse bit but they pretty much perfected
it in 1953 so this shoe is now 70 years
old it looks as good now as it did the
day it was invented and this shoe is
like so instantly iconic obviously as
you've seen you know throughout this
video there are a lot of horse bit
options out there now but Gucci still
sort of rises above the pack for a few
reasons in my mind one is like this soft
imitated never quite perfected shape
this is such a distinct shape of shoe
it's like not quite Square toed not
quite fully rounded just very beautiful
classic you know sort of moccasin style
you know the other is the quality right
it's made in Italy of really beautiful
leather that's gonna you know last a
really really long time it's like so
soft and supple Straight Out of the Box
you know unlike how kind of tough and
cool that that bass we regions leather
is but this is like the opposite this is
like you put this on and it just feels
so nice against your foot so these will
cost you almost a thousand dollars they
clock in at 920 that is I grant you a
very large amount of money to spend on a
pair of shoes but I would also argue
that you pay that much and you will get
a ton a ton of wear out of these they
are like heirloom quality your grandson
will be so chuffed to be like hell yeah
I got my grandpa's beat to Gucci
loafers and they look sick there's an
extra auditory element to it like with
the little jingle it sounds like money
in your pocket which you won't have any
if you buy classic shoe totally worth
the money in my opinion so good yeah if
you can afford them then you know great
for you my second pick in the no budget
category are these really beautiful
loafers from John lobb John lobb is a
very traditional English brand it's been
around for I want to say like over 150
years they have a history of amazing
bespoke shoemaking these are no slouch
by comparison like these are from their
main line you know you can buy them like
this ready to go side note looking at it
from this angle when you were holding it
young like in contrast to the bass
loafers like the two-tone is so subtle I
could barely even notice it for sure
which is really sick doesn't have that
pop of contrast that the past regions
has but just a beautiful beautiful shoe
last but not least
um in this category I wanted to shout
out Belgian shoes which is a classic
classic New York store it's been there
since the 50s they specialize in Belgian
loafers which are a very specific kind
of shoe they're very rakish they have
sort of like an aggressively low cut
Vamp and a little bow tie which is
really cute there's some instances where
where they feel a little more formal
like a black pair of belgians looks
amazing with the tux I have a pair and I
really like to wear them with anything
like you know like like I think they
come in a lot of really cool colors
Belgian shoes is like a very small hole
in the wall store in the Upper East Side
you know yeah they don't they don't they
don't sell their shoes online you have
to like literally like make a pilgrimage
to this tiny little hole in the wall to
buy these shoes no matter what you're
wearing them with they're gonna stand
out because they've got the little bow
tie they're very particular they're like
like a shoe that a lot of people have
never seen before paired with jeans
paired with pair of shorts that we keep
saying like like they they look really
sick and I wear mine all the time with
with all sorts of stuff
so yeah so those are all of our picks
today
um you know as you can see there is like
a massive spectrum of loafers available
but they're all really great they all
are super super versatile and you know
no matter what your budget or taste is
there's a great pair of loafers out
there for you and I hope we prove that
today thank you guys so much once again
for tuning in and as always if you see
anything you like you can check out all
the links immediately below
[Music]